hey hello drew how are you dear
oh my goodness i only miss i can't be
there and give you a hug
i know i wish i could give you a hug too
and i was looking at this picture of us
from boys on the side
and just thinking does it feel like it
was yesterday does it feel like a long
time ago what is time and space
but it was just nice to look at it
that yeah does it feel like yesterday
does it feel like
60 years ago i mean
but now i'm looking at that i remember
where we were tucson arizona
we leave the set you uh uh i remember i
was driving a little blue truck we drive
back to tucson from the set
i remember you telling me how much you
loved avocados back then
i would like to be buried under an
avocado tree
i would yes and you
were like playing the bongos that i
remember that was happening a lot when
you were off work
yes i was i've been playing played
bongos long before i got arrested for
playing bongos
i just was like someone who plays the
bongos that's just
uh so unique and i i love
the poetry of the way you speak and
think
and i've been having the most incredible
time reading your book
thank you thank you thank you i i was
hoping you would like you would like it
well i love that in the opening you say
this is an approach book i
i really fell in love with that you talk
about this is not an advice book you are
not preaching although you do love
preachers
and it also says this is a playbook
based on adventures from my life
and it is such an amazing way to get
insight
into your life's journeys but it's just
so full
of takeaways you know i call it an
approach book
as you said not an advice book because
nobody likes to be told what to do i
know especially i don't
but i did i did have a great time
sharing some stories of my own life
things approaches to life that i've
taken that have
given me satisfaction approaches i've
taken that
i failed at and and luckily kept
sort of notes and journals over 36 years
of successes
and failures cools and shamefuls along
the way
and um it was fun to put them down on
the page and share them and
you know i'm hearing from different
people how it's translating to them per
them individually and how they're
getting a laugh out of or getting some
wisdom out of it and that that makes me
makes my heart swell there is uh
something i also circled and it's the
story of when
you were starting out you
you know thought should i try method
acting should i study you were studying
you thought maybe you were getting too
intense about it were you losing a sense
of that
improv and freedom and like swagger and
so you just went onto a set
and didn't know anything because you
thought it would like
work in your favor to be kind of easy
going and groovy
turns out you had a four-page monologue
in spanish
and you said this is so important
we have to prepare to have freedom
you have to do the work in order to do
the job i just think that that
is such important that is an important
life
lesson and has incredible advice yeah i
learned that the hard way
um from that story and if you want a
good laugh check that one out because
boy was i
embarrassed i i i didn't look at the
script i didn't look at the scene i
didn't look at anything i just said i'll
go there and i'll just do what my man
would do
you know well when it was a four-page
monologue
and then i get in my head that i think
well i took a semester of spanish in the
11th grade
if i just take 12 minutes off maybe i
can go memorize 12 minutes
12 4 pages of spanish uh negatory
um i've never been able to to watch that
scene i don't know what i ended up doing
but i know i didn't do a four-page
monologue in spanish like i was supposed
to
that is my worst nightmare i do have
nightmares and like
terror dreams that i show up to work
empty-handed
and because you know everyone's waiting
around on you just staring
and and you ca it's not an option and i
so i just reading that i was like oh my
gosh this is like
reading about my own subconscious
nightmares
yes it's it's i've broken i i've woken
up in the middle of the night cold sweat
with that fear before myself had you
always wanted to write a book was it a
bucket list thing
something you thought of when you were
younger like brass ring frodo
later on or was it after the life
was consumed you thought now i have
something to write about i think it came
later i mean look for the last 15 years
i've been looking over at this treasure
chest full of journals that i've been
keeping and writing for the last 36
years and so that treasure chest has
gotten full i take it with me wherever i
go
and for the last 15 years i've looked at
that treasure chest daily and said you
need to go away and see what's in there
and then a couple years ago i got the
courage to say you know what i've got
some time off i'm gonna go away on my
own
solitary confinement see what i got with
a kick in the backside from my wife
camilla telling me do not come back home
until you do have something um so i
loaded up with my favorite liquor a
bunch of steaks a bunch of water
headed out and didn't come back until i
had some i love that
story uh so very much and i'm so glad
that you did do that may i ask do
you have any suggestions on why
journaling is important
yeah you know i mean i started off
keeping a journal when i was 14. i think
like most
young probably more young women but also
some young men do it for
at that age i mean i was writing down i
was confused
who the hell am i why did gretchen
donnelly break up with me why do i have
pimples on my face
you know i was asking those awkward
questions and then i later on
continued to write when things were
going well when i felt like i
had found my frequency when i was in the
flow of life when i was succeeding when
my relationships were healthy
with the hunch which turned out to be
true that oh i'll get in a rut again
i'll get off frequency but now i have
something i can look back at and go
well what were you doing when you were
in the flow mcconaughey and plus what
journaling does for me
is i've said this at the beginning of
the book i don't write things down so i
can remember i write them down so i can
forget them
you know when you get a good idea or
something crosses you
don't forget that thing don't forget
that thing well if you go write it down
you can forget it and go oh i've got it
written down i can go back and trust
that that that inspiration i had
is there so i don't have to run around
while talking to somebody thinking about
oh i gotta make sure to remember that
i'm really glad i asked because i took
the i write things down to forget it in
a different way when i was reading the
book
and i almost thought it was like to work
it out get past it and then move on
you're talking about being able to relax
because it is so exhausting to try and
remember all these things that
we want to remember they're important to
us they mean something
wow okay i'm really glad i got you know
you and i are i say you and i are out of
dinner
and you say something that inspires me
i'll pick up the
the phone and i'll be writing it down
and i'll have to say hey i'm not writing
someone that's not here i'm actually
writing something down that you just
said that i want to
deconstruct or bring up to you later um
if i don't write that down
then the rest of our conversation 10 of
my mind's going don't forget that thing
don't forget that
so i'm not actually not present with you
yeah right so i love to write it down
and before phones i would write it down
on my arm
and take a picture you know take a
picture of the sharpie thing i wrote
them up a beer coaster a napkin
what have you